just 16 for 77 the last two games listen
they play what we refer to as hero ball
game seven excited they wanted every
player to be pretty kitty they wanted to
shoot the three they they were actually
trying to get the crowd involved but
when they went zero for ten they start
the game to start the game that should
actually zero for 12. yeah zero that
should have sold that quarter yeah that
should have told them hey settle it down
let's get the you know Pace the game
back in our favorite let's take high
percentage shots and let's take the wide
open shots well there's a reason Ernie
that it's never happened in the history
of basketball there is there's a
difficulty in winning four straight
games after losing three so there are
there's no room for error there's no
room for letdown there's no room for
human nature there's no room for
anything that you they put themselves in
it wasn't the fact I don't feel like
they could have a game like this but if
you played your first three games in a
different manner you're not even putting
yourself in a position yeah there's a
reason it's never happened in history of
basketball yeah but Ernie listen Kenny
right but this is the thing about the
Celtics like we said we never know how
they're gonna play this is one of the
most inconsistent talented teams I've
ever been around you got two guys who
are all NBA you got the defensive player
of the year you got the Sixth Man of the
Year and in the last month since the
playoffs started a couple games you say
what the hell happened against Atlanta
what the hell happened against the
Sixers and then you come out here and
you get down 3-0 with the first two
games at home then you play two
magnificent games then you really play
three magnificent quarters then you try
to choke game six away
I'm not I mean I'm surprised I'm shocked
that Miami won the game but I'm I'm not
shocked they won the game I'm shocked
they won by 20. yeah for the second
straight postseason the Celtics with six
home losses in their gym wow in a
postseason first 75 years of Team
history it never happened
um and they get knocked out here in the
Eastern Conference Finals that's not
what you call Championship caliber
uh you know they tried to do it the hard
way didn't get accomplished listen I'm
I'm not a shooter I play with a lot of
great Shooters Glen Rice D Scott and the
reason why I say mix it up this is what
the gray Shooters I play with you meant
these guys missed two shots he's putting
his head down Kenny you missed two shots
you're putting your head now you're
mixing up when my team goes zero for ten
the first quarter you know what I'm
telling everybody don't shoot another
three shoot another three and I'm
punching your face let's get the ball on
the side let's take hopperson no
seriously yeah this is a game seven
clothes again my team is zero for ten in
the first quarter I'm going to the bench
and say next person shooter three I'm
punching it in your face but the one
thing that disappoint me go back and
look at the entire season
I think what happens is when you got
really really good players you can make
tough shots
but you can't survive on tough shots you
survive on open shots and layups and
mid-range and things like that your
culture so they when you because you can
get a shot I mean Kenny's the best
shooter on this show easily
and he knows give me a on what
percentage would you shoot on wide open
shots
wide open threes probably closer to 60
55 60 contested threes you're in the
like 30s so it balances out to like if
you're a good shooter like four and
that's the thing and people act like man
this is basketball nobody survives on
tough shots defense rebounded and easy
shots always are going to be the way to
be successful you know you just can't
survive the way that you can win some
games question for the panel here uh
because after three games of this series
when uh Boston was down three love
there was talk is Joe Missoula the man
for this job
he forces the Celtics force a game seven
now the quest is Joe Missoula the man
for the job first okay me and Chuck we
have a different perspective on this
you know Chuck believes like for me it's
you know coaches X's and O's pre-game
speech but me as the president of the
team as the leader of the team is my job
to get myself going and it's my job to
show the guys that hey this is game
seven I come to play follow me if you
don't want to follow me throw me the
ball and get out my way I don't really
rely on you know coaches coaches coaches
I feel you always have to do by yourself
I've always done it by myself I've had
great guys that give great speeches
prepare rally and Phil Jackson gave
great motivation speeches but I knew
coming in and hey I got to get it done
and I don't need them to say come on I
knew what I had to do to get it going
you know my perspective on that for me I
think coaching is more than just
motivating you I think it's it's more
than speeches yeah it's 100
um there's execution there's thought
process and you ask the question you
asked is Joe Missoula unequivocally I
think yes because he's this is his first
use the man for the job it's his first
year in a situation and he's got his
team to the Eastern capital his finals
one of the four best teams in basketball
okay did he make a couple of egregious
plays in earlier series possibly but
they got through those this series was
more about monitoring what he will learn
as a coach from an outside looking in I
just feel that he will learn that when
we go over 12 it's also not it's my
responsibility to figure out what play
to call that creates penetration and
does not make us a perimeter team that's
the difference so when you ask me would
I keep shooting I would shoot open
threes but I would think how do I get a
penetration play for Clyde Drexler for
Hakeem Olajuwon Vernon Maxwell because
we're staying too perimeter we used to
call it mooning people we're staying
around the moon and we have to figure
out a way so that's where I think Joe's
Zula can fine tune his fine tune things
and help his players be great
and they have great players I would
never say a coach should get fired uh
coach Missoula did a good job he made
some mistakes all coaches make mistakes
I didn't like his answer about we did
the shop being less relied on the three
men Shaq disagree Shaq don't think coach
is important at all
and check the reason I just well first
of all coaching is important but the
biggest problem I have with what you say
is you are a great great player I don't
think coaches are bought in to help the
best player I think they're bought in to
help the other players like if a guy
who's great gonna always be great but
I think the one thing that SPO does he
gets those guys so much confidence
struce Duncan Robinson Caleb Caleb
Martin you can see they play free and uh
Gabe Benson they never turn down an open
shot Kenny what can a coach do for you
he can't give you confidence but what he
can take it away yes but and my question
is when he says no about live and die by
threes
a great coach said one time I love
listening to great coaches because I
think what they said well he says you're
not coaching it but you're allowing it
to happen
so it's your fault either way you're
either coaching it or allowing it to
happen and we sit here for the last
seven games and their strategy is we're
just going to jack up a bunch of Threes
if they go in we're gonna win don't go
and we're gonna lose that's not gonna
work man you got to have a plan B 9 for
42 from Deep tonight Boston Celtics fall
to the Miami Heat who are the Eastern
Conference champions heading to the NBA
finals against Denver
103-84 Jimmy Butler 28-7-6 Caleb Martin
had 26 and 10. that's in the word of the
night Caleb Chuck I've been up Shack for
vacation season Henry